Noah was a just man and
perfect in his generations.
And Noah walked with God.
That's an interesting line because if you
remember back in the story of Adam and
Eve,
what happens to Adam once he
eats the fruit of the tree,
of the knowledge of good and evil and
wakes up the scales fall from his eyes,
become self conscious,
develops the knowledge of good and evil
is he won't walk with God when God calls
him in the garden.
And so Noah is Adam without
the fall essentially.
And there's something that
Noah is doing right that
motivates God to spare him or maybe to
show him a pathway through the emergent
chaos,
something like that.
And that's worth thinking about a lot
because there will be situations in your
life where what you face
is the emergent chaos.
And maybe that'll be some terrible
catastrophe inside your family.
Or maybe it'll be something that's
occurring on a much broader social level.
But the chaos is coming and what you're
going to want to know unless you want to
be a dentist and of the chaos
or even a contributor to it.
And perhaps that is what you want because
many people under those circumstances
choose that.
What you want is to know
how you build an Ark and get through it.
That's what you,
if you're,
if you're interested in life,
if you're interested in proper being and
you're disinclined to produce any more
suffering,
the necessary,
then you want to know how
to conduct yourself when the
catastrophe comes so that
you have a reasonable possibility of
okay,
of moving through it and,
and starting a new.
So when,
when this old story says,
well,
God's not happy and he's
going to wipe everything out,
it's like,
well,
you might want to take that seriously.
And then when it says,
but there's one person who had a motive
being that protected him from that.
That's also something you might want to
take seriously because you might want to
know what that mode of being is
because you might need to use it.
And so these sorts of things are
practical in the deepest possible sense.
They're real in the deepest possible sense
and practical in the deepest possible
sense.